We are taking calls via discord at David Pakman
dotcom slash discord.
Let's go to Venice, Italy, and speak to Emilio
Amelio.
I am tentatively going to be in Venice in
10 months for a wedding if it all goes well.
Really, very much so, I'm telling the truth.
Have perfect I'm glad that you can have this
opportunity to visit this beautiful city.
I look forward to it.
Thank you for picking up my call, and I would
like to tell you that you have a very beautiful
show.
Thank you.
I cannot support you right now because my
comment now is an intermeeting based show.
As Amelio That's OK.
You're supporting us by just calling in and
saying nice things.
And I would like to talk to you to talk to
you about a friend of mine.
She was at the elementary with me.
You see her?
She has her father is American, OK?
And she moved back to New York.
And before the election, she and his father,
they moved back to Italy and they left the
house and a job, everything, because she was
really scared of all the situation about the
pandemic and of the turnout of the election,
OK.
And from there, I start looking more dedicate
more time to all this matter because I always
keep an eye on international news.
But it was really upsetting.
All the orders, all the thing is going on
in your country.
Yes.
But really, that is an understatement.
Upsetting is an understatement.
I agree with you.
I'm so thank you for my call and have a nice
day.
All right.
Very good.
I appreciate it.
Yes.
And if you if you don't have a flood the apartment,
you can contact me.
Oh, all right.
Maybe I will stay with you.
Yeah.
Would we have to share a bed or would I get
a sleeping bag or.
No, we we sometimes we rent a little, but
not a very nice apartment.
So if you if you are in if you like this opportunity
and didn't have to hold on, did you say little
and very nice or little and not very nice.
Not very, very nice.
OK.
All right.
Amelio I like the sound of that.
Amelio, thank you so much.
You're welcome.
Bye.
All right.
Emilio from Venice, Italy.
What a call that is just wild, wild stuff